what's up everyone its tomorrow and I'm
joined by Dave Jewett which can only
mean one thing
we are here to talk about Warhammer last
time we were here we were talking about
Diablo in 40k in 4k now we had talked
about
XCOM it's basically XCOM so what is this
game okay
it's called mechanicus and on the very
surface level it is very much XCOM now
I'm gonna try not to get into too much
like the nerdy nitty-gritty stuff but
you're you play as priests from the
mechanicals of Mars okay and basically
for people who don't actually care that
much about Warhammer all you need to
know is they love machines they are
quite happy chopping their limbs off to
replace them with robot ones and they
they just they just worship technology
sounds like the human race in the modern
day almost except if the human race
gouged out their own eyes and put laser
beams in them it's only a few years away
from that yeah
Elon Musk is working on it like 30 a
millennium we're fine yeah so this is
mechanicus on the very surface like I
said it's ex-con so these what you're
seeing now is basically I'm starting a
mission these are the two tech priests
that I that I take on and these there
will be a lot of parallels Tech's come
in this in this video these are your
soldiers hmm these are called your
canticles and these are basically your
buffs for the match so you can have
things like +1 resistance to energy
attacks +1 damage to physical +3 defense
all that sort of stuff and then when you
want your mission you get into the nurse
fear now the nurse fear is just like a
nerdy Warhammer would it's basically how
the tech priests and the mechanicus talk
to each other because they're all robot
people they turn on robot language it's
the internet for them it's yeah it's
basically like brain Wi-Fi yeah but this
is what you see when you're setting up
your mission so I've launched onto the
planet now and we're fighting the
necrons which basically an ancient race
of robot dudes and then I happy and I'm
here to mess things up so I've launched
onto their world and you start off with
this kind of tactical map and you
explore all the rooms that connected to
the
the starting room in this tactical map
and and you'll get things like emergent
story like like here I've found like an
artifact and you get to decide what to
do with that artifact now that has
gained me data in the short term in the
long term it's also going to affect your
relationship with the other mechanicus
that you're working with one of them is
super strict and don't doesn't like you
messing with any technology the other
one is super lenient and likes to absorb
alien technology into their own was
usually a big no-no so you'll end up
it'll end up affecting your relationship
with your own team right so that's
interesting because XCOM allows you to
customize characters and invest in them
but there's not a lot of interpersonal
interactions between them so this is
that's what kind of what distinguishes
this from pure ex-con right yeah you've
got you've there's a lot of a choice in
in what you do it's it on the surface
level like I say when you're actually
getting into the combat that it has
taken a lot of hints from why would be
recognizable from XCOM but you could go
through these missions and there could
be a chance that you don't actually find
anyone but what you see in the top left
is the awakening meter and because
you're on a necron world the longer that
you stay on this world the more necrons
wake up and the more dangerous they
become and the more they chase you and
the more damage they do but eventually
you you will come into a fight I've got
the loading screen there just for the
time say but now obviously it's gone or
green which usually means the necrons
have turned up so now we're finally in
the actual meat of the game yeah this is
what the combat looks like and the
combat it's it's it's very interesting
what they've done with it so you can see
those three gold cogs on the left of
these necrons there that is your
cognition points and basically with the
way that it's it's very very connected
to the law of Warhammer so much so that
they've actually got been counter if
you're what I'm a fan he's written some
really good books so it's like they've
got their nerd chops basically so super
deepens the law so the idea being is
that your tech priests they're like
they're not the best of fighting so
first of all they've brought in two of
them either you get
like entourage almost spending what
items you have or upgrades you have or
what perks you have you might have a
perk to bring in a soldier you might
have a perk to bring in a service or you
might to bring in any any suite of
additional supporting so you can have up
to 16 units on the field but the idea is
is that the mechanicus they're based
around technology so in order to to act
properly they need information they need
data
so those cognition points you need to
scan those in order to do your your your
best map moves your best attacks move
further so in the bottom left you don't
see on this character because he's a
very basic counter he's he's one that's
pretty much expendable it's the guys and
the red robes that you need to really
focus on you can see here the bottom
you've the blue ones are free but the
ones that are grayed out you need the
cognition points to use right and that
represents just like in the wide law
sense that the more information that
mechanicus has the more powerful they
become so once you scan those you can
use your much more powerful attacks
that's an interesting kind of twist that
you don't see that often it kind of
reminds me of resource gathering from
traditional RTS and and even a bit of
like mobile stuff where you don't
automatically start off with the most
powerful attacks you need to level up as
you go along by killing creeps and enemy
here yes and then you unlock the more
powerful stuff so it's a nice like
strategic consideration on top of like
maneuvering and finding the rest of the
rest of the best way to approach each
skirmish yeah come on it's fun it's like
like that's top-down controlling units
so the instant parallel is XCOM the way
the moment-to-moment gameplay is quite
different like there's there's no cover
for example everything's done on like
like saves and chances to hit so I was
talking about and I said how have you
have you balanced that because most
attacks will have 100% chance to hit and
they said they did that because you want
it to be fun right and there's nothing
like one of the biggest frustrations in
XCOM was
getting right up close to an enemy yeah
having a 95% chance to hit and then it's
completely whipping it so if you if you
want to dodge an attack or if you want
attack to miss then you have to you have
to interact with it in some way you have
to use an ability or have a very slim
chance to roll so it's much more action
focused but like I said that is still a
big element of strategy when you when
you're deciding what abilities to use
because there's like an there's a finite
number of cognition points see you might
scan all these cognition points use your
super powerful attacks which are now on
the bots on the boss in their orange but
you could blow all your powerful attacks
and then like a team Lord Turner and
you're just stuck with a load of like
trash tier attacks so that's really
where the brunt of other strategy comes
in what abilities your guys have what
abilities do the necrons have how how do
they play in tandem at first it seemed
quite basic but then when he was
explaining to me the more units you get
and just the sheer number of just
responses that you can create it did
start to get more and more tactical
but I thought without without the cover
system I was like gonna be really that
tactical but I didn't find myself
missing anything like that also seems to
provide you with more of a reason to go
a little more exploring and minding cuz
you obviously you're gonna the further
out you go the more the higher chance
you have to unlock cognition points and
that kind of business so it's kind of
like a split focused thing for me from
the looks of it like you want to have in
XCOM everything I wonder where plays
everything I do is is oriented around
maneuvering around enemies and finding
the best like points to attack they have
objectives but they're like you usually
fulfill those objective objectives as
you're taking out enemies yeah this is
more like if I've got 16 people to you
know keep a keep an eye on I can send
some of them off to unlock cognition
points while the others kind of engage
the enemy and and then like swap them
back and forth so it seems like they're
trying to add a little more strategic
layers to it and there's there'll be
some levels where you have to like flip
switches to unlock the rest of the level
like to create bridges or you'll you'll
be chased by infinite
infinite waves of enemies that you can't
escape and at that point you have to you
will get to a point where you have to
sacrifice your lesser units you're
expendable ones like the servitors in
this Qatari to get your your robe guys
your actual priests to where they need
to be right and it's it again plays to
the law of Warhammer they're like it's
it's it it's pretty crap out there so
some of your guys are gonna die right
and that's just completely unavoidable
and it's just something you should
accept right off the bat right but he
mentioned the like you ever get into
like a cycle when you played XCOM games
you've faced a really tough level all
your high level dudes die
mmm but then you need to play that level
but now you're stuck with lower level
dudes all the fruits which makes it
harder and you're stuck in this cycle
and so eventually you're pretty screwed
you just give up there's there's like an
element in in 40k where these mechanicus
can basically just take a chip out their
brain and put it in someone else they've
got the right resources so to get out of
that kind of infinite death loop you are
able if any of your main guys do die you
do get a chance to resurrect them so
it's not right like the complete end of
the world but you will have to use like
some some very rare resources and is it
like instant like you get the chip
straight away or is that like recover
the chip first from the dead body we
didn't actually see it this was like a
concept that will be in the final game
cuz yeah this is this is like super
super early alpha as you can see from
the handy little watermark on the on the
bottom right yeah it's worth emphasizing
that they they did stress that a lot of
this is placeholder stuff they want
their kid like the UI and the UI the
fonts that the animations on on the
tactical maps all super super early I
was actually impressed with like how
early they were happy to show it yeah
it's not often we get to see a game in
this extreme early stage but they're
also very confident in it so that's a
bonus as well yeah but one thing worth
noting is that the campaign is only ever
going to be 30 instant like 30 missions
long so at the starts like they didn't
want to give away too much the story but
to start you've turned up on this world
and the necrons of about to do some you
know ancient robot stuff about to pop
off and you get 30 missions in order to
level up enough gather enough resources
gather enough equipment take on any mini
bosses and then on 30th turn like that's
it yeah like you you better be ready
because big man team was coming for you
it's a run based I'm kind of like you
want oh yeah introduces that
replayability where the next time you do
it if you fail you know maybe I'll try
this route instead not take on this boss
instead of four instead focus on growing
this character over here and see if I
can that's an interesting way to
introduce replayability and ease the
missions didn't seem that long you can
do like two of them in like maybe ten
minutes and as you get more powerful
you'll be obviously more confident to
find them this is one of the new enemies
they showed me that the flayed ones and
the way they act is they will always
target the enemy unit with the least
health so you'll be all charging that
one guy and then there's like now that
guy's like oh I'm in line but you
mentioned replayability
they may be because there's two factions
that you're kind of working alongside
one of the factions was literally called
Metallica and they're from a planet
that's just all coated in metal which is
like the most rad because there are like
two siding factions there may be an
element of if you've cited one faction
your replay the other faction but
abandon you for your second run oh I
have to kind of recreate your your kind
of party but you'll be able to customize
your guys completely at the start of the
game you'll be able to choose the colors
of your guys if you want if you want
dudes like bright pink robes
knock yourself out if you want to stay
quite and quote true to the Warhammer
games workshop colors then you can be
red but you can completely customize
on a cosmetic level but also on a like a
an item level hmm so this guy Jeremiah
he's got he's got big axe and then he's
got a cannon attached to his back they
were these massive backpacks by as I
mentioned before they in the law of the
mechanicus don't hold flesh to any high
regard it's not like like we're precious
why I lost a limb I'd be like that sucks
the 41st millennium they're like oh
please take it off me so I can replay it
replace it with like a robot 1 mm and
when you start these guys are organic Oh
but throughout the game if you find a
cool power cloth your guys will be more
than happy for you to remove one ions
and put that there
they said one of the hardest things to
implement was the ability to chop the
lower torso off of one of your guys and
replace it with spider legs because he's
like we spent so much time creating
these like 3d models of people but now
we have to add spider legs so it's again
it's very early but I'm I'm really
excited to play more of this ex-con was
my jamm warhammers my jam hmm any
Warhammer fan is probably gonna love
this I hope it follows similar trends of
other Warhammer games that it can be
accessible enough for people yeah to get
into the into the Hobby it looks
promising and I'm sure that Warhammer
fans will be very vocal when it's out
whether they like you oh they always are
yeah and we don't currently have a
release date is that they've told me end
of 2018
okay so exact that but I have I have
spared you all the really really new you
can you can hit Dave up on Twitter oh
yeah I'm a regular Dave if you want to
know all the nerdy stuff and tweet me or
leave it in the comments if you feel bad
for some more personal and talk to me
about solid metal gear solid terrace
house yeah at to more hey I only talk to
me about war and only Warhammer
and now and we'll see you next time for
more war hammer or hammer but in but in
XYZ